MINNESOTA -- THE TIP DIOP
PRESENTED BY CARMAX.
ERNIE JOHNSS, SHAQUILLE O'NEAL.
KENNY "JET" JOHNSON, AND THEN
CHARLES BARKLEY.
>> I SEE PEOPLE MESSING WITH MY
OLDER BROTHER.
>> MESSING WITH YOUR OLDER
BROTHER?
OR MAYBE CLAPPING BACK.
>> Shaquille: YEAH, CLAPPING
BACK.
>> Charles: IT SHOULDN'T BOTHER
YOU.
>> Ernie: WHAT DO YOU HAVE,
JEREMY?
EASY MONEY SNIPER, THAT WOULD BE
K.D.
PUT ME A PICTURE OF ME AND THREE
OLD GUYS ON THERE.
HE HAD A COUPLE, THOUGH.
>> Ernie: WHERE WOULD CHUCK BE
WITHOUT THE BIG HOMIES?
>> WE DIDN'T WIN TOGETHER.
WHEN I WAS A BUS DRIVER, I
DIDN'T WIN ANYTHING, JUST LIKE
HIM.
>> WHO WASSED BUS DRIVER?
>> Charles: NOBODY.
I WAS A ROOKIE, THEY WERE ALL
PAST THEIR PRIME.
>> Ernie: THERE YOU GO.
>> Shaquille: WHAT WE'RE ABOUT
TO DO IS GO BACK, BACK INTO
TIME.
>> Kenny: I THINK, FOR ME --
>> Ernie: LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT
THIS, TOO.
IT'S OKAY TO DEFEND YOURSELF,
BUT THE MISTAKE WAS -- THEY HAVE
AN ARMY OF PRODUCERS
EXPERIENCED.
THEY'RE GOING TO BE IN PHOTOSHOP
ALL DAY.
THE STAGE DIRECTORS PROBABLY
SETTING UP FOR A BAND.
K.D. SAYS AN ARMY OF PRODUCERS
AGAINST THE GOD.
CONDITION CONDITION YOU MEAN THE
GOD SITTING AT HOME.
YOU THINK THEY PUT THAT BANNER
UP ALREADY?
LISTEN, I CAN PUT UP STUFF ABOUT
HIM, RUSSELL, JAILS AND SERGE
IBAKA.
I SAID, WAIT A MINUTE, I'M NOT
GOING TO RESPOND.
YOU WANT ME TO PUT UP HIM, RUSS,
JAMES, SERGE IBAKA?
I SAID, NO, K.D. IS A GREAT
PLAYER.
THE POINT I WAS MAKE IS --
THE
BUS DRIVER FOR ME.
>> Charles: YOU'RE NOT IN THIS
CONVERSATION.
>> Kenny: YES, I AM.
MY POINT IS, WHEN YOU SAY IT,
BUT DRIVERS, TO ME IT
DISRESPECTS YOU.
>> Charles: IT'S NOT
DISRESPECTING ME.
>> Kenny: WAIT A MINUTE.
WHAT YOU HAVE ACCOMPLISHED.
THEN IT GIVES THE IGNORANT, OH,
HE DIDN'T WIN A CHAMPIONSHIP,
HE'S NOT GREAT.
>> Charles: YOU SAY IT EVERY
WEEK.
>> Kenny: I NEVER SAID YOU
WEREN'T GREAT.
WAIT.
TIME-OUT.
I NEVER SAID YOU WEREN'T A
CHAMPION.
THERE'S A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
WINNING A CHAMPIONSHIP AND BEING
A CHAMPION.
SO, WAIT, JUST IN MY BOOKS, I
THINK YOU ARE A CHAMPION, BUT IT
GOES TO SO MANY OTHER THINGS AND
VARIABLES TO WIN A CHAMPIONSHIP.
TO SAY, BUS DRIVER, THE
AVERAGE -- THIS IS WHAT I'M
SAYING.
THE PERSON WHO DOESN'T KNOW
BASKETBALL.
>> Charles: THEY'RE NOT IN THE
CONVERSATION.
NO, THEY'RE NOT.
DUDE, WE'RE NOT PAYING THE
INTERNET ANY INTENTION.
>> Kenny: THEN, WHY DO WE SHOW
THE INTERNET?
THEY'RE UNINFORMED.
>> Charles: THEY DON'T GET IT.
>> Shaquille: EVERYONE DOESN'T
HAVE A SAY-SO.
BUS DRIVER MEANS IT'S YOUR TEAM.
THAT'S WHAT IT MEANS.
>> Ernie: THE POINT HE'S MAKING
IS LIFE IS DIFFERENT.
CONDITION CONDITION LOGIC IS AN
ENEMY AND THE TRUTH IS A MENACE,
SO THEY DON'T GET IT.
YOU CAN'T ALWAYS SAY THINGS --
>> Charles: YES, YOU CAN.
CONDITION CONDITION IT'S OVER
THEIR HEAD.
>> Charles: NO, IT'S NOT.
WHEN I'M IN THE ROOM WITH OTHER
HALL OF FAMERS, WHO GET TO SIT
AT THE TABLE, THAT'S THE WAY IT
IS.
>> Kenny: YOU'RE A CHAMPION.
WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT?
THAT'S MY POINT.
TO ME IT DOESN'T MAKE SENS